الصحفيون والمراسلون قد يكون هذا العامل
اسوا بالنسبه لهذا القطاع اذ سجلت منظمه
مراسلون بلا حدود رقما قياسيا في الحصيله
السنويه للانتهاكات المرتكبه ضد الصحفيين
عبر العالم حيث بلغ عدد المحتجزين
الاعلاميين
50033 اييي بزياده قدرها
13.4% مقارنه بالعام الماضي بينما رصدت
المنظمه الحقيقيه مقتل سبعه 57 صحفيا على
مدى الاشهر الاثنى عشر الماضيه بزياده
وصلت الى
18.8% يتوسع اكثر من نصف الصحافيين
المسجونين في العالم اعتبارا من الاول من
ديسمبر على خمس دول وايران هي الدوله
الوحيده التي انضمت الى هذه القائمه
القاتمه هذه السنه وفقمه اوضحت المنظمه
التي تصدر هذا التعداد السنوي منذ نحو
عقدين ونصف
اكد الامين العام للمنظمه المدافعه عن
حوريه الصحافه كريستوف ديلوار على ضروره
الصمود في وجه الانظمه الديكتاتوريه
والمتسلطه التي تقوم بحشو سجونها بصوره
متسارعه من خلال اعتقال الصحفيين وزجهم في
السجون
اذا ايران احتلت المرتبه الثالثه بحسب
مراسلين بلا حدود وقد تتصدر القائمه
السوداء بما انها تشهد احتجاجات ستتم فيها
الثلاثه اشهر بعد يومين وكل ما ارتفع صوت
الغاضبين اشتدت يد النظام قمعا خاصه تلك
التي تنقل ما يجري في الشوارع الى الشاشات
والصحف حيث نشرت لجنه متابعه اوضاع
الصحفيين المعتقلين قائمه النهائيه عن
اوضاع خمس 35 صحافيا اعتقلوا وما يزالون
رهن الاحتجاجات وبحسب تقرير اللجنه اعتقلت
ايران منذ بدايه الاحتجاجات وبناء على
تقارير رسميه وغير رسميه نحو 70 صحفيه تم
الافراج عن نصفهم تقريبا
من ابرز هذه الاسماء نيلوفر حمدي مراسله
صحيفه شرق الاصلاحيه تم اعتقالها في
الثاني والعشرين من سبتمبر في طهران لانها
نشرت اخبار عن مقتل مهساين لاول مره كما
اعتقلت قوات النظام الايراني خصر كورد بور
رئيس تحرير موقع موكليان الفارسي الكرديه
واطلقت صراحه واعادت اعتقاله مجددا واخوه
ايضا مسعود كوردبور مدير تحرير موقريان
مازال رحنا لاعتقال اضافه لفاطمه رجب
الناشطه في مجال حقوق المراه ومن بين
الصحفيين المعتقلين ايضا الها محمدي
مراسله صحيفه هم مهنه في العاصمه طهران
والقي القبض عليها بسبب تقرير لها عن
ملابسات مقتل امين بحسب محاميها